Kim Kardashian has a mini meltdown while  vacationing in Mexico I'm just liking  why did I come you know Kim is still  dealing with the aftermath of her  terrifying Paris robbery a year later  it was really tough for me in a new  teaser for Sunday's Keeping Up with the  Kardashians  the reality star fears for her safety  and breaks down during a phone call  while staying at her Pal Joey Francis  Villa Kim was robbed at gunpoint last  October she explains why the traumatic  experience has left her scarred ever  since Paris I've just like go through  this like worst-case scenario mode in my  head I was so excited to come on this  trip and I had no idea that I was gonna  end up feeling this way but it hit me  bright as we were getting off the plane  that all of these people at the airport  are gonna see you know 17 or 18 girls  with all of our Chanel bags and you know  Louie Vuitton this and it just like hit  me like we're the biggest target ever